so today we're very honored to have
arthur greeton from university of
college of london
he actually traveled quite far away to
come here and give a talk and he's
apparently super well known for his work
on kernel method and
and today he's going to share us with
some of his recent work on energy best
based models and without any further ado
yeah please take it away okay uh yeah so
thank you um
so yeah the talk is going to be on a
topic called generalized energy-based
models um so
just to set the scene uh the task of
this talk or the purpose of this talk is
training generative models
so many of the previous speakers talked
about
generative adversarial networks there's
one mechanism for doing that
this talk is going to be
following that theme but not using an
optimization viewpoint but where we're
going to be talking more about the kinds
of problems we're trying to solve when
we're training such networks okay
and how to basically improve these
models
all right so
just to set the notation
our real samples are always going to be
p
they're going to be in blue
our generated samples are going to be q
they're going to be red
and generally when we're training a
generative model
we have a loss function which tells us
how far the real and the fake samples
are apart from each other
so again to give notation and this is a
graphical notation i'll use throughout
the talk
our generator is going to make fake
images here badly drawn dogs
the critic is going to compare these
badly done dogs to
reference dogs is going to back to the
generator okay
so this is a classic gun
uh
also in the classic gun literature once
this model is trained you take your
predict you throw it in the trash and
you just use the generator on its own
so i'm going to argue that this is a bad
idea
in that if my model isn't perfect this
critic still knows something about the
mismatch between the model and the data
and we should be able to improve our
generative model by incorporating that
information rather than throwing it away
all right
so this gives then rise to the outline
of the talk
first i'll talk about divergences there
are two categories of divergence that
matter one are the integral probability
metrics
matrix
among which the washer stein and mmd
distances
the other are the few divergences or f
divergences among which kl jensen
shannon chi squared and so on
what i'm going to argue in the first
part of the talk is that the
divergences being used to train again
are always closer to the first category
even if they're initially explained in
terms of the second category so
what people say when they're when they
say they're using feed divergences to
train again is in fact something much
closer to an itm okay so maybe
controversial so
you can
make angry zoom comments
then i'm going to use these divergences
rather than throwing them away after
training the model i'm going to show how
to incorporate these divergences to
train what school they generalized in
the device model
now an energy-based model
is usually
defined where the model and the data
have the same support a generalized
energy-based model is a energy-based
model in the circumstance where the
model has a low dimensional support i'm
trying to generate let's say images in
pixel space it's a much lower
dimensional sub manifold
and in this case uh it's very likely
that our model and our data won't have
support that overlaps perfectly like
maybe they'll cross only onsets measure
zero
um so in that case can i still define an
energy function does it even make sense
to define an energy function for such
models and how do i train it right
um
interestingly you know these two
categories all these two the topic areas
are going to be overlapping as we're
going to see
so
you know just to recap from the previous
slide a generalized energy model is like
a gun but it's going to use the critic
function as part of the sample generated
generation mechanism
and all else being equal
we're going to see that it's always
better than using the generator on its
own because as long as the critic has
some information it's going to be useful
all right
okay so let's think about divergence
measures for a moment so broadly
speaking there are two ways in which one
can think about a discrepancy between
distributions right
one is there's a difference in measures
and one is as a ratio okay so if the
difference is zero p and q are the same
if the ratio however we've chosen to
define it is one then p and q are the
same
right
now within this category of divergences
we have the integral probability metrics
where we're basically looking for a
function from some well-behaved class of
functions it maximizes the difference in
expectation okay
um so this is our way of witnessing p
minus q so to speak
whereas uh in the feed divergence
category the way that we witness the
ratio of p to q is that we ensure that p
and q have densities and then we take
the expectation of a function of that
ratio
now this function
should return zero when the ratio is one
because when the ratio is one pink we're
the same
and we're also going to see that it's
going to be helpful to us that this is a
convex function for reasons we'll see
shortly
all right so let's spend a little time
on this side to explain what these are
doing so these are the integral
probability metrics
what these do
as i mentioned is they look for a
well-behaved function which maximizes
the difference in expectations under p
and q
so if i'm talking about the western
stein distances then these are the
functions whose lipschitz norm is going
to be bounded by one
and what we can see here is that as the
samples from q approach in the samples
from p
the wasserstein distance is going to be
decreasing in a
well behaved way
um so i'm going to denote that as a sort
of a helpful critic a constructive
critic because uh as my red is
approaching my blue so as my fake
samples approach my reel
even if the support doesn't overlap my
wall sustain is dropping down
and that was one of the big motivators
for the wasting
gans for instance which use was the same
distance as a
critic
mmd also has this property of being a
helpful critic so the mmd
also decreases in a nice way
as the red samples approach blue so the
mmd as its critic class is using
functions that are reproducing kernel
hobbit space which are smooth functions
again with the norm upper bounded by one
and so this is again a well-behaved
predict class okay
um so what's important about these
credit classes about the ipms more
generally is that they behave well even
when the support of red and blue don't
overlap okay
now
let's spend some time on this side the
feed divergences
um so among which helen jerry pi is
great and so on
um which depend on the ratio of pdq
okay
um so remember you know
the divergence is the expectation of a
ratio function of a ratio of p to q
when p on q is one that should be zero
and phi is going to be a convex function
for reasons that will be useful shortly
okay
famous example fear of u is u log u so
that's the k of divergence so we all
know love
right now here's a problem right
if the support of p and q don't overlap
then
these are very unhelpful predict
functions right so in this instance for
example the kl divergence is just
infinite
and the jensen shannon distance is log 2
but it's log 2 like regardless of where
i move my red around
now if i'm training a generative model
particularly in high dimensions like an
image space
it will almost always be the case at the
support of my model in my data overlap
and so uh as uh adolf quinbo to point
out
an ipm an integral probability metric is
effectively never a good idea in this
circumstance um and yet you know
thousands of grand papers are using
proportively ipms to train so what's
going on
okay
um
so let's
understand a little bit better what's
going on
by considering
what you know it is that people are
actually doing when they say that
they're using ipms to train again okay
so here is a feed divergence expectation
under q of fee of ratio pdq
i can express this because phi is convex
as the solution of an optimization
problem
so basically for every value of z at
which i evaluate that ratio i can solve
for
a scalar fc
which maximizes the pro the
this this
quantity here so ratio p to q fc minus v
star of fc
now phi star is the joule of the
function so basically that's like a
slope intercept form of that function
like you give it the slope it gives you
the negative intercept
and for a strictly convex function
that's a like a unique representation of
that function okay
now if you solve that problem for every
z you're going to recover your original
function again
all right
what happens now if we don't solve the
problem exactly what if we just solve it
approximately so what if in particular
we require that this function of z
should be a smooth function of z
all right in that circumstance what
we're going to do is we're going to get
a lower bound okay
and i've just rearranged it slightly
so i'm going to say that now i'm
considering a smooth set of functions
and i'm going to have like you know e p
of f minus eq of v star of f
as my my lower bound on my original feed
divergence okay
when is this bound tight
the bound is tight as long as you know
uh in my class of functions i can attain
this f diamond okay which is the
derivative of fee evaluated at the ratio
of p and q okay if that's the case then
you know i'm able to just plug that in
and recover the original
okay
right so now let's look at the case of
ko because that's one of the best known
feed divergences so here is my kl
divergence log ratio of p and q
integrated over pvc
here is the lower bound where we've
plugged in the form of the joule okay
i've used a particular form of my
functions which is minus f plus one
rather than f that's going to be useful
for later in the talk but it's just a
minor
notational change
so this is now my my lower bound on my
original kl using some smooth positive
functions across a function that's
varying smoothly
with the z
okay
when is the bound tight well it's tight
when my uh class of functions here
contains f diamond which is the negative
uh log ratio of p on q um so that's uh
the form that it oops you have the form
that it takes when i'm using
uh kl
okay so for example
let's say that my p and q are gaussians
with different mean same variants
in this case if the straight lines are
in my class of h
calligraphic h
then
indeed i'll be able to attain this
supremum
and so now
what happens if we want to estimate this
from samples well i just would replace
my population means with sample mean so
then i'd get an approximation to this
quantity based on some number of samples
which hopefully is going to become more
accurate as i see more samples
okay
so this is our kale approximate lower
bound estimator
or the kale divergence which is not the
same as the kale divergence
now how does this
kl divergence so how does this lower
bound behave in practice okay
so here is my
optimization over some smooth class of
functions of this epf minus eq e to the
minus f plus one
for these slides here
i'm going to be using a reproducing
conohobit space as my class of functions
and i'm going to put a roughness penalty
on it so very similar to the mmd
um so because it's a smoothness penalty
we'll call it the kale smoothie
here is my tail uh in the case where
i've got the same
example as earlier where i've got my two
sets of points
um
and what you can see is that this is
acting a lot more like an ipm right so
these two sets of points have no
overlapping support
and yet this is not infinity
it's something that's behaving much more
sensibly
and in particular as
my red approaches my blue we're just
seeing here empirically that indeed the
kale is going down
so unlike the original kl divergence
which would be infinity here and here
here we're getting some view that the
red points are approaching our blue
so this is something i'll make a bit
more formal later
but you can sort of see how it is that
this
smooth lower bound
is a much more informative critic
function so a
helpful critic function
when witnessing the difference in the
distributions for red and blue
yeah so um these variational lower
bounds these are what are used in gas
so you know when people say they're
using jensen chen and they're using a
smoother amount on the jensen channel
when you're saying you're using ko
you're actually using the smooth floor
volume kale
so
any like there was a wonderful review
paper in fact by novozin or a very good
paper by novozin czech and tomeoka who
basically
set out for all of your favorite feed
divergences what these smooth lower
bounds look like um and then just did
gan for all of them
but
you know the original feed divergence is
only defined when the ratio is defined
which it never is
in any of the problems that people care
about so these are this is always uh
you know some variant of this is always
what's done yeah
yeah
though it seems that the difference is
uh there is
unlike
so here i've made an explicit
regularization for a particular class of
functions but you know when one is
training guns
the
requirement that the critic function
should be smooth is somehow like
interesting so for example um
when you're training again you're
alternating between updating your
fitting in your generator
if you have a look this is something we
did in relatively low dimensions just to
visualize um
initially your credit function class
when you haven't paid it very much like
when you've got weights close to
randomization
is actually a quite broad critic
function so it's not um
there is a smoothness which arises
because i haven't optimized the weights
very much
and as i train my gun more and more in
fact the critic function becomes sharper
and sharper more concentrated around my
real samples
so this is something that we've we've
observed at least in our experiments
yeah
and i'd
like to understand that better
in theory but in practice this is what
we see yeah
so you know there is always going to be
some requirement that it doesn't go off
to infinity on the real samples and go
to
you know minus infinity on the fake
samples let's say yeah
we shouldn't train with this
if there is no uh way to
require the discriminator to stay smooth
then you should finish yeah
um but you know there's endless uh
like these spectral regularization
training like there's all these
different ways of making the game very
smooth
um and so yeah and and that's required
because the support never overlaps
yeah
but for the support arguments and you
could always assume that the
generator supports everyone and so
we don't have this program though uh
let's return to that so the generator
support won't be everywhere uh in cases
you care about because your generator
takes a low dimensional source and
always pushes it through them yeah so
you're gonna see yeah
um yeah
okay
um
so let's look at uh some
uh like uh this you know what i've shown
here is a sort of intuition
uh let's formalize a little bit more uh
what this means okay
um so
for you know one one uh property that we
might wish for for this scale divergence
is that when p and q agree this should
be
zero okay
um and it should be like non-negative
when p and q disagree
for that you need a rich enough set of
discriminating functions okay because it
has to be large enough that whatever the
difference in p and q i'm gonna see it
this will be the case when our set of
critic functions is dense in the space
of continuous functions
which is true for example if i'm using a
universal reproducing kind of hobbit
space
one can also show that this is the case
for a
neural net class in a limit as it
becomes infinitely wide
with you know just a single layer so
basically i look at the spans
of value style functions
across uh all i find transformations of
my data
and that's also reaching our function
class even though it's a little bit
theoretical because of course you know i
i need to have infinitely many such
values so it has to be infinitely wide
um nonetheless you know
this is a class of functions that is
rich enough
all right
another requirement which i think is is
a much more important one
uh is that
what we want is that kl should converge
nicely to zero
as q approaches p
and this was the essential property that
we saw was true for integral probability
matrix and we want to establish that
it's true
for our
tail what we can show in the event that
our h is lipschitz with constant l
is that the kale inherits the property
of the wasserstein that it goes to zero
when q converges weakly to p
uh now i don't want this to be
mysterious so i'm going to explain why
that's the case okay so here is just a
sort of high level sketch of the proof
idea
here is our payoff so minus fdp minus t
to the minus 52 plus 1.
i'm going to just add and subtract the
expectation of f so expectation of f dq
and then minus
expectation of f dq so this guy here not
that there okay
then i'm going to notice that actually
this thing here is always greater than
or equal to zero
and that's the proof right so then i
basically i'm subtracting something
that's positive so i can upper bound
this by my you know expectation of fdq
minus expectation of ftp
and then you know because we know that
our h is lipschitz with constant l i can
upper bound that in turn by l times the
was sustained one distance and i know
that when q weekly converges to p that
goes to zero and therefore this gets
sandwiched down to zero because it's
always non-negative
so i'm inheriting this nice property of
wasserstein with my kale
and so that's the quick overview of
probability metrics are there any
questions before i go on
so
yep like yeah the yeah
c f is in the h
[Music]
oh yeah so we need uh right then you can
scale it up for something if you
integrate this you have like all the
powers of c
times f that should be the h
so so
i mean maybe it's okay but like it feels
like um
basically
c has to be smaller than one or
something no because c-max has to smell
that one right uh i will i see what
you're saying yeah i know i would have
to
if that requirement
is in the paper
um yeah i would have to guess that but
it does make sense no i i see exactly
right um so it's
not negative because
if f
is in the function plus then minus that
is in the function class in this sense
so i have um
when i'm
let's see
when i'm
choosing my functions i have linear
transfer functions here
so i should be able to
the supreme should always be
yeah i
i believe so right yeah
if i have like
yeah like if f is in the thing that
minus f is a thing so it should work out
right
yeah
i quit so it's true but i again i need
to think about it yeah
you're right i mean never see it um so i
thought this negative next
yeah
uh i just think about how i'm quite
confident in it that i would have to
check the proof yeah
yeah okay
so um
let's now look at the generalized energy
based model okay so we're going to use
our critic as a
function for this gun
so
this is uh relating to the question we
had earlier which is that if you know we
are sure that our generator is creating
samples in a low dimensional sub
manifold in the higher dimensional space
because we have this you know how does
the generator work it takes a low
dimensional source of noise pushes it
through a bunch of you know filters
and then gets a higher dimensional
output like an image let's say
so we are confident that it will be in
fact on a low dimensional sub manifold
so now just to give the
idea of a generalized energy based model
in the fewest number of dimensions that
we can get away with
let's say that our target distribution
is in a one dimensional sub manifold in
a 2d ambient space so this is what we
have here
so here
my target is to generate samples on this
wiggly line where we notice that we have
denser samples towards the end and
sparser samples towards the middle
okay
now let's say that we've produced a
generator which is able to get the
support correct okay just to start with
so in this case i take a low dimensional
source of noise i push that through my
beta which is my generating system
and
i then get this wiggly line but without
the right
density along that line okay
um
then what i would want to do is to i
re-weight the generator points uh or you
know importance weight them so that i
upgrade the points here
and downward the points in the middle
and so this energy function achieves
that
but notice that the energy function is
defined not just along the support but
on the whole space
so now let's look at what's much more
likely just to be seen in practice which
is that in practice the support of my uh
model
probably is not going to overlap
perfectly with the support of my data
and in fact what's more likely to happen
is that the overlap will happen on sets
of measure zero at best okay
in that case
i can still define and learn an energy
function that will increase the weight
of the points towards the end and
decrease them towards the middle
which will make my red samples match my
blue samples better
okay and so this is what i mean when i
say generalized energy it's not like a
traditional energy based model the p and
q have to have the same support and
often they both have densities with
respect to the leg
in this case
p and q needn't have the same support
which is you know what's likely to
happen in practice but i still want to
be able to re-weight or importance
weight my samples using an energy
function so that my red is closer to my
blue
so does that idea make sense
so now i've defined the intuition how do
we achieve that in practice and in
particular what does this energy
function have to do with this critic
function that we've spent all over that
time defining
okay
so
let's say that here is my again
generating process right i take a low
dimensional source noise push it through
a filter get an x and that's my
generator output
okay
then i want to take those samples and
importance weight them by an energy
function so i've got my e to the minus
energy or x minus energy
with the normalizer
and then this gives a re-weighted set of
samples along the support of my
generator
and that's
this this also needs to be learned so
now i'm learning two things i'm learning
my
my generator parameters
and i'm learning my energy function
which rewrites those samples
okay
so you know in the event that q has
density with respect to the big measure
um then this just becomes a
basic energy-based model um and these
have been studied
very extensively
by many different authors so you know
what it does do is to reduce back to a
classic energy based model
in the event that i do have a density
with respect to their leg
but what i'm interested in is the case
that i don't
and in particular in the case where q
and p don't have overlapping support um
yeah
the other thing is you know how do i
actually sample from such a model well
the importance weighting is not a very
efficient way to go about that
so what i might want to do is to do
something a little bit more clever and
we're going to see
that we can actually do uh
we can sample from this model by
changing the distribution over the
latent z that we sample from so this
distribution here is going to change
rather than trying to do importance
weighting on my x space
so that's an important uh trick to make
this thing work
okay
so
how do we learn the energy function e
and what does energy have to do with a
gan critic
okay
so
to optimize e we would want to
optimize something that looks like an
expected log likelihood and that's the
expression we have here so expectation
and the q
of log of r f right
which i can then express as
the integral of minus edp minus log z2
okay where this is the normalizing
constant so just to remind everyone the
zq
ensures that my model is correctly
normalized
okay
so
if p and q had density with respect to
the veg
then this would be optimized when the
energy function is just the log p on q
so basically at that point i'd be doing
importance weighting
um and this would then be a don's per
variant lower bound on kl
which becomes tight when i hit the right
importance weighting
weights for my energy function
but you know as i i want to emphasize
um
you know this generalized likelihood is
defined for mutually singular
distributions
um and so uh you know i'm still able to
optimize it and and reduce it uh in that
in that setting
this still doesn't look like a 3d
function okay so what do we do next
so here is the expression from the
previous slide the generalized log
likelihood
minus edp minus delta sum x uh e
eq
there is one last trick which is that we
lower bound this negative log sum x
with this quantity here
okay
which becomes tight when c hits the
normalizer so basically like i'm
estimating
my normalizer of my model as a parameter
of my model as well as uh the e function
and in practice i'm going to you know do
sgd on both e and c
so i'm going to optimize both of them
over many batches
um so if i substitute that in
i have
negative minus e plus c dp minus e to
the
minus e plus c d q plus one
and then this should look familiar to
you because this is the kl
it's the kale where my class of
functions is the energy and the
normalizer
so basically what we've shown is that
this particular critic function
ends up giving us
a
an energy function for a generalized
energy-based model if we use that as our
credit class
so there are questions about that before
i go on yeah so to be clear so you have
already trained q in some other way and
now you're trying to adjust it
that is a good question um so we are
going to trim this actually as we
retrain again
so we're going to alternate between
training critic and generator yeah
so yeah it's not going to be sort of
training fuel on its own so yeah
that's that's a that is for that
[Music]
okay so actually now to get the um to
return to your question about training
the generator um so remember that our
generator takes a source of noise pushes
it through some filters and gets an x
um and let's say that you know i'm
defining k of theta is this function for
a particular energy and normalizer
okay
so then the gradient
with respect the gradient of this k
as long as i've
evaluated my e at the optimum which
we'll
speak about in a moment
is given by this expression here which
we can evaluate okay even though it
looks a little messy
we have made
smoothness assumptions about our energy
function and about the mapping between
both our parameters and our z
to this b z b theta z function which are
here
and these are required uh to do this
computation
what you'll notice though is that this
is valid only when e is e-star
um and then you know there's been i
think a number of talks in this workshop
about how to sort of do alternating
training between generator and critic
when you've got an adversarial min max
problem
uh so i kind of like swept all of that
under the rug here
um
[Music]
my my or the approach that we take to
sort of like push ourselves
a little bit more towards this scenario
is that we do indeed train the energy uh
like
for several steps uh for each step of uh
each gradient step we take on the theta
so we basically optimize the energy for
a few steps then take a gradient step on
theta then optimize uh e again
you know more times uh and then a single
gradient step
so we're basically like doing more steps
on e than we do on theta
if that makes sense um
this is of course uh you know a
heuristic but it's a heuristic that's
motivated by this
expression
sorry if my question is
i'm not sure i understand the difference
between this energy
the standard formulation where they
cannot see the discriminator as you know
giving a sort of energy of like a fake
so that's exactly the right intuition so
the uh critic of the gun uh does do
exactly that
so now the question is well why throw
that away
okay why not use it to help your gun to
be better but so when you you don't use
it yet not yet okay in a moment yeah and
so because you have regularized your e
now you
are allowing yourself to optimize it
more the radius
we shouldn't look for e-star or like
that
saturates the
but not in this case because of the
i mean keep in mind you know all of
these are population expectations right
and so when i talk about e-star it's
sort of in an infinite limit and so
you know if i've got finite examples
then at that point i i need to like i
can't over uh optimize my e so let's
play together
and it won't give a divergence that uh
right i mean that's
of course the uh risk when you do over
as you eat in the early stages you're
going to get a really similar food there
anymore so you're absolutely right yeah
okay so now the question how do i use
the energy function to improve my
samples
okay
um so a naive way would be really to
just treat the energy function as an
importance rate and start throwing away
samples that have low importance weight
and keeping samples that have high
but that's very inefficient so that's
definitely not what we want to do
okay
so
we are going to do something quite a bit
smaller than that um so let's say that
i've got my x which is you know b theta
z z is drawn from eta and then
you know i want to basically do
the equivalent step to doing this
re-weighting here
um
the way to understand what that
equivalent step looks like is to take
the expectation of a function under my
model okay so here i'm saying i want to
take the expectation of something g of x
under my model density and we choose to
say g of b
on z
weighted by f b e a b z e to z dz
now looking at this form you can sort of
say well what would i need to do to
change my z distribution to have the
same effect when i'm taking my
expectation
and the answer is well if i could make
my z distribution eta weighted by
fbe bz
then that would have the same effect as
doing this weighting here when i'm
taking an expectation of a function
so what we do is we don't sample anymore
from eta on its own we sample from this
new distribution
and we do that using like your your
favorite uh i mean we have gradients
here so we could use like uh hamiltonian
monte carlo or
whatever your favorite uh login added
fusion-based algorithm is
so we can do this very efficiently
and in particular
we're in a low dimensional space so um
you know this this sunflower is going to
mix pretty fast as long as it's well
designed
so basically what we're doing is that
we're sampling from parts of the z-space
which are more likely to generate good
samples
and we're sampling from less of the
space which generates terrible samples
and you know good and terrible is
informed by this energy function
are there questions about that
okay
uh so now uh
i think it's
always essential to give experiments if
you're talking about guns
um
so
uh first of all um
you know here are some trajectories that
we're getting when we're running this
generalized energy based model
um for uh i guess uh
you know
various starting points okay
um
what we're doing is to run it at a low
temperature so it climbs up and hits the
mode
and what you're seeing here in these
slides is that you're getting something
that sort of
converges to
a nice image as my sampler runs in the
in the z space
[Music]
uh
that's uh i'll show you here
uh oh this is actually still at the
lower temperature so it's still biased
towards modes um but i uh in here we've
decreased the friction so it's sort of
bouncing from mode to mode
and what you can see here is that it's
basically like hitting
you know one thing and then it's moving
to another mode and then it's moving to
another mode
so it's kind of cool like it's sort of
biased towards spending time on the
modes but it's exploring from mode to
mode as the sampler runs in the latent
space sorry this is at low temperature
so we're running at low temperature
which biases us towards the modes um but
we've reduced the friction compared to
here so here it sort of like goes up to
a mode and gets stuck
whereas here uh we drop the friction so
we're going to hold and then going down
to another motor yeah so it's uh
then the mode is slightly out because
the temperature is low um but the
friction is though so it can jump
forward
so if you think of that hmc um
uh you can uh or an hmc style algorithm
there are sort of two things one can
control so one is the temperatures
obviously
you can also reduce or increase the
friction of your
like uh
let's say you know you the little metal
ball that is sort of going along these
surfaces
um
and so if you
introduce friction it's going to sort of
be more likely to get stuck on a boat
because
yeah you suffer your momentum um and
then you uh
you know
have been given that momentum you run it
project right um
friction is something else because i can
i can say rather than just stopping my
trajectory i can say like my particle as
it does the movement is subject to
friction so it's being slowed down as it
does its motion
which is you know different to just
stopping it after some arbitrary amount
of time
so yeah there is a certain amount of
engineering behind uh getting good
samples here and designing your software
yeah
so just to understand this together
you have your generator that's fixed and
then you just like issues uh on the z
space
and then you get like what right right
so yeah at this point everything has
been done so energy function is fixed
generator is fixed and now we're just
something from our world
yeah
yeah so there is no more uh adjustment
to energy or diffusion at this point
this is
so when i say that we sample a z
we have to run out the fusion algorithm
to sample the z
right because there's something from
this distribution here
so yeah so when we say i sample a z i
get a sample from a good part of my z
space and not like a happy place
yeah so the other i think uh
point to make is that
um i trained at the beginning of the
talk that uh all else being equal you're
always better off using the gantry to
inform your
supper rather than just using the
generator
so what we've done here is to you know
have like again architecture with a tail
fitting
uh for
a whole bunch of different datasets
right um
the uh score that we've got here is fid
so lower aesthetic
the reference of 100 is just i began on
its own like forget about using the
predict function just like gun generator
and nothing else
what we show in red here is the
improvement in it id we get by including
the quiz
and what's interesting at least the
cluster data that we've looked at is
that we're always going to do better
and so this is pretty nice that it's uh
yeah
these other methods that we're comparing
against they're also using the uh
predicted information
but in a more heuristic way so basically
they're saying well you know i start
with a
sample for my generator and then i move
it maybe one or two steps uh according
to the gradient of my uh creating
questions
um and try and then get a slightly
different example
um so these are like along the right
track
and they're always improving uh over
let's say a generator on its own
um but we're able to do better again
than this uh across the locality
okay
um
yes actually uh
that pretty much concludes the
presentation um so here is the paper and
you know the important thing is that we
do have code
so you can try it for yourselves
um what's interesting is that uh within
actually a couple of days of this
another paper came out from uh
which had the same idea
uh but using jensen and rana and kl
um so basically like you know these two
arrived at the same time
um
and you know it turns out that what
they're doing uh and what we're doing
are super super related um so i
encourage you to look at this paper as
well um
and then to see uh how these two relate
um
there's also some very nice papers in
the pyramid and i clear obscure
with this idea of
changing the distribution of the latent
uh sample space so as to improve the
samples within error again
so these two papers
give these approaches
um so again like you know i try to look
at those
um yeah and
i'm happy to take further questions now
could you just have a little bit of the
uh
sort of like the computational aspects
of the training
like uh
so
so
when you say computational aspects like
what do you have okay people are just
saying
but
so i guess yeah
i mean i would say it's very similar in
the sense that like
having more steps for your predict than
your generator seems to be a sensible
thing
um
i haven't uh
it might have
been helpful actually to have that stuff
but i can sort of describe to you um one
of the things that we noticed and one of
the most important things i think
foreign
is that in the early stages of the
training you should have a very broad
very smooth energy function and then in
the later stages you're going to have a
targeted one
the other point is that the energy
function
it's a
it's not a sort of isotropic general
smoothness that it has it's an actual
it's a very
uh data dependence for this
so
uh for example as you move along the
manifold of the real data
my energy function tends to be more
smooth after training than if i move
away from that data manifold
so it's not that i'm sort of having a
function that's smooth in 10 million
dimensions which is a very impossible
thing
um it's actually sort of
smooth uh
only within let's say certain uh
directions of motion and
not uh elsewhere
so yeah so the these
properties that we noticed are very
important but
we would like to be able to say more
about that setting
in understanding guns and how they
behave i think that's an important
direction
um 10 questions regarding the training
procedure
your generated distribution depends on
your generation
so
when you buy propagates you know when
you get the gradient of the
discriminator you have gradient for the
you know everything depends on
everything else and so in principle um
yeah
what we're doing is kind of like uh
pretending that that's not the case um
for the purposes of paying but that's i
think a challenge around optimizing
anything where you've solved this sort
of structure and we uh
more or less just adopt the kinds of
heuristics that people have used in
practice rather than uh resolving that
question i would
yeah so that's um yeah uh during
training we just alternate the two once
training is uh reached an equilibrium
then we
freeze everything and then we start
using
yeah think you could um that could
actually be interesting yeah um
what i wonder about though is whether
uh
the
if you did that
the energy function then might uh
let's say
okay what might happen is that your
generator might then
uh
do less well than it should do or it
would be able to do because it's like my
my energy function is taking some of the
burden of putting samples in the right
place so then my generator doesn't have
to adjust its own
placement of probability that's not
manifold
it's an interesting question it might
even be a good idea just because
then in a sense you're giving the
generator only the task of getting the
support right and it doesn't have to get
them that's right
so it could actually end up being
another idea yeah that's an interesting
idea
yeah it's uh
one
uh challenge might be that you're gonna
then have to incorporate hmc something
within your uh optimization which you
know
uh
may not be a bad thing um
but one would have to be careful about
things like you know what temperature
you wanted to add how much you know
you know so that we get like a new set
of uh
um
[Music]